I think there are a lot of restrictions
I think now there's I think that there
are a lot of restrictions of covering
the war but and I think that you know
you see herbs and flows of media
coverage of the war I don't think it's
enough I don't think it's not but I
think that we we it's not just the media
but we as Americans as the citizens
citizens have a also responsible I mean
there's there's the idea of war fatigue
again you know in feature films that you
know are failing at the box office
because they have to do with the war
documentaries that are failing because
they have to do with the war and their
the whole idea of where fatigue is is
really disturbing I mean we the least we
can do is continue to absorb and the
information about what's what's
happening but so I think it's I think
it's media and it's also an individual's
responsibility
you